[Applaudissements]
offert en spectacle et franck camus il
va rester là parce que on va faire la
surprise avec camille il ya quelqu'un
qui a souhaité vous faire une surprise
ce soir elle est là tu as ta rentrée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un moule avec toi c'est mon prof
de chant jack hill et elle sait n'aime
pas on est très contents de vous avoir
hélène ségara d'autant plus hélène je
vous le dis c'est que vous étiez venu
nous voir donc à l'époque pour pour
votre disque 1 hélène et c'est vrai que
thierry moreau ne croyait pas du tout à
la ce duo entre on a des images regarder
le croyez pas du tout à hélène ségara et
joe dassin regardez j'ai beaucoup
accroché avec l'album vous ne connaissez
la croche jean michel maire aussi
christophe carrière thierry moreau - que
se passe-t-il aux accents funk you
non je ne suis pas détracteurs d'hélène
simplement je trouve que c'est un coup
marketing
je sais pas s'il vient des enfants de
joe dassin ou de vous mais ça sent le
coup le coup mart et qui pour surfer sur
la popularité de joe dassin ou en plus
je suis pas très fan de joe dassin au
départ donc ça aide pas et puis le seul
qui est au champs elysées je trouve que
le reste c'est des duos et que voilà ça
c'est dit j'essaie de te faire quelque
chose différent moi tout est l'idée
d'aller chercher un mort qui me gêne
mais il est vous savez une voix ses
éternelles alors donc ses rivaux n'y
croyais pas
hélas hélas non vous êtes venu pour
faire une petite surprise à franck ça
nous fait très plaisir de vous avoir
pillé en plus je lui ai dit on en avait
discuté après chacun a droit d'exprimer
son sentiment par rapport à cet album
avoirs libyens dans le micro est bien
celui-là aussi la banque a placé un coup
martin luther king n'aime ça je vais le
redire
et là je vous dire non vous a fait venir
pour que vous fassiez une petite
surprise à franck dubosc revient copines
ou un site web mais on vous a pas fait
venir pour ça ils aident vous à venir
surtout parce que nous on a une surprise
pour vous et l'aisne
parce que vous êtes disque de platine
[Applaudissements]
les listes de matière
[Musique]
mon beauf mais si tout va bien
hélène et vous le verrez thénac ça nous
fait plaisir
hélène ségara je voulais vous dire un
truc que je vous regarde tout le temps
ça m'a beaucoup touché est ce que tu as
dit quelques jours après ça m'a vraiment
beaucoup touché c'est ici que j'ai fait
ma première télé pour cet album est de
toute façon je suis quelqu'un qui
accepte les critiques
je suis ouverte au dialogue mais en fait
ce qui s'est passé après tu le sais toi
tu avais gardé le secret bien en fait ce
que tu as dit ça m'a vraiment voilà je
vous remercie madame
[Applaudissements]